jeff bezos went from getting his dream
job as the youngest ever vp at a hedge
fund to quitting founding amazon from
his garage and writing his business plan
while driving across the country from
new york to seattle to becoming the
world's first center billionaire and
have an estimated net worth of 176
billion dollars here's my take on this
top 10 rule to success
enjoy
[Music]
my view on work like work life balance
is that i prefer the phrase
work life harmony
to me
balance implies a strict trade-off
and i have seen
situations where people
are they have all the time in the world
maybe they're out of work
they have lots of time
you know it's they don't have they have
all all the time and they're so stressed
that they're actually terrible at home
everybody at home is like well i'm sure
we should get a job
um
and uh
my sister-in-law says for better for
worse but not for lunch
and
so it's you you've you you
you really want harmony you want a um if
you're happy at work
if you're finding meaning in your work
if you are um
it can be hard they call it work for a
reason it's not going to be fun all the
time that's a
pipe dream
none of us enjoys every minute of every
day
and to have that kind of idea would just
be naive
but there should be fun at work you
should be laughing there should be
moments of joy
um
and if you're getting energy from work
instead of your work draining your
energy then you're going to come home
and you're going to be
a better mother
a better father a better wife a better
husband all those things you're going to
want to take out the trash
and so even before being asked that's
what's going to happen larry she's going
to say
who is this guy
and so
you really need to
i think if you're starting to get to the
point where you are worried about
work-life balance i would challenge you
to think
is just something out of whack it's
probably not the hours look you can if
you're working 120 hours a week
you're also doing something wrong that's
too much
it's not sustainable maybe you can do
that for a week or two but that's it
but if you're working you know
60 hours a week
that's completely sustainable for most
people
and the question if you're burned out by
it it's not the number of hours
it's the s so you're doing something
wrong you need to figure out what it is
because you're going to take that home
and then your home life is going to be
stressful and then you're going to bring
that back into
the office so it's going to be a
negative spiral and that spiral will
also be a positive one as soon as you
turn it around rule number two follow
your passions i think um to some degree
uh you follow your passions
and then wait the you know you have to
hope the wave catches you i was always
interested in computers
um i was always interested in software
i was always a big reader and so it
wasn't you know
which made me alert to things like the
internet um
and the possibility that you could build
a bookstore online that would have
universal selection
and that was really the founding idea of
amazon and so
i think everybody has their own
passion their own thing that they're
interested in and then you're very alert
to the things that
that are in the sphere of influence of
that passion
so your passion has led you to change
the world frankly with amazon but yet
you've got blue origin you've got
basil's explorations why can't somebody
like you just rest on your laurels
well i you know i love what i do i have
um i also have four kids i have a wife
that i love i have a lot of passions and
interests
but i one of them is
you know at amazon
the rate of change is so high and i love
that i love the
i love the pace of change
i love the fact that i get to work
with these
smart big smart teams
the people i work with are so smart and
they all they're self-selected for
loving to invent on behalf of customers
and so you know it's not uh
i do i love every moment of every
day no that's why they call it work
there's you know there's always there
are things that i
that i don't enjoy but if i'm really
objective about it and i look at it i'm
so lucky to be working
alongside all these passionate people
and i love it why would i
why would i go sit on a beach rule
number three avoid having regrets i did
do a lot of soul searching i i went to
my boss at the time and i really liked
my job and i told my boss i was going to
go do this thing start an internet
bookstore
and
my wife and i had already told my wife
and she she's like great let's go
um and i
i said to my bosses and he's like this
is a good idea he said i think this is a
good idea but it would be an even better
idea for somebody who didn't already
have a good job
and that sort of made some logical sense
to me and he convinced me to think about
it for a couple days so i went away i
was really trying to get my head around
how to think about this and i think
for me the right way to make that kind
of very personal decision because those
decisions are personal they're not like
data-driven business decisions they're
they are you know what does your heart
say and for me
it was i could the best way to think
about it was to project myself forward
to age 80 and say look when i'm 80 years
old i want to have minimized the number
of regrets that i have i don't want to
be 80 years old in a quiet moment of
reflection thinking back over my life
and and cataloging a bunch of major
regrets
and i think that regrets our biggest
regrets in most cases you can murder
somebody okay you'd regret that but in
most cases
our biggest regrets turn out to be acts
of omission it's paths not taken and
they haunt us we wonder what would have
happened i loved that person and i never
told them and then they married somebody
else i did you know i didn't do this and
so that's the frame of mind that i put
myself in and i and once i did that once
i thought about it that way it was
immediately obvious to me i knew
that when i'm 80
i would never regret
trying this thing that i was super
excited about
and failing if it failed
fine i would be very proud of the fact
when i'm 80 that i tried
and i also um knew that it would always
haunt me if i didn't try
and so that would be a regret it would
be a 100 chance of a regret if i didn't
try and basically a zero percent chance
of regret if i tried and failed so i
think that's a useful metric for any
important life decision rule number four
have professional pride the professional
pride part is so important
because ninety percent of what all of
you do
nobody ever sees
it's something it's inside the work
people see something
finished
but they don't see what's inside it only
you see that
while you're doing the work
and that so you have those and those
things can't be great since nobody's
seen them nobody's inspecting it you're
not going to get any credit for it
the only thing that's going to make you
have high standards on that piece of the
work that nobody's ever going to see
is your own professional pride in
operational excellence those are the
four cultural attributes
that are at amazon we use the same ones
with blorzen we use the same ones at aws
those things
i would if they start to
erode at the edges that would make me
very nervous so i spent a lot of time
trying to inspect that audit that teach
that
teaching things like that is about
repetition
senior leaders
need to be broken records
on the things that are important to the
organization
and if everybody in the organization
like you you have succeeded when you
start to see people roll their eyes
because of your repetition
on certain important things because
senior leaders don't have to do a lot of
things they have to pick a few big ideas
and enforce tough execution against
those big ideas and that requires a lot
of repetition
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five start small is
there a particular recipe that you have
in terms of how you actually innovate in
that collaborative culture
i think um i don't i don't think there's
a particular recipe but there are
elements of what we do
that i think help so
one of them is that
inside our culture
we
understand that even though we have some
big businesses
new businesses start out small
and so you know it we it would be very
easy for say the person who runs
our us books
category to say why are we doing these
experiments
with things i mean you know
that generated you know tiny bit of
revenue last year
um uh why don't we instead focus those
resources and that uh you know that all
that brain power
on
this on the books category where we
which is a big business for us
and
instead that would be a natural thing to
have happen but instead inside amazon
you know when a new business you know
reaches some small milestone of sales uh
email messages go around and everybody's
you know giving virtual high fives for
reaching that milestone and i think it's
because we know from our past
experiences that big things start small
uh you know
the biggest oak starts from an acorn and
you've got to recognize if you want to
do anything new
you've got to be willing to let that
acorn grow into a little sapling and
then finally into a small tree and maybe
one day it'll be
a big business on its own and in fact
that's one of the mottos for one of your
initiatives and forgive my my
pronunciation of the latin but greta
team for oct what does that mean to you
well it means
step by step ferociously and it's the
motto for blue origin
and
basically
you can't skip steps you have to put one
foot in front of the other things take
time
you there are no shortcuts
and but but you want to do those steps
with you know passion and
ferocity rule number six have a
beginner's mind one of the great
paradoxes of inventing at a high level
is that you need to be an expert in your
domain area and you need to have a
beginner's mind
you absolutely need both of those things
the world is too complex to actually
just be a beginner so you know i can't
no matter how inventive i am i can't go
invent a new kind of brain surgery
you have to be a neurosurgeon you have
to already know all there is to know
about brain surgery and then take it to
the next level the problem is for many
people by the time they become
true experts
they've lost that ability to see things
in a fresh way
they've lost the beginner's mind
and so that's another thing you always
need to be stepping back and saying if
i'm an expert i'm an expert in launch
vehicles or whatever it is
i i need to step back
and say okay
what if i were looking at this for the
first time what would i be seeing and
noticing these are just some of the
things you need to do to be innovative
rule number seven
this isn't seven rule number seven deal
with failure that was a good one let's
talk about failures i know amazon has
had its share of failures in fact
i remember having been part of some of
them
at amazon
i'm curious to know
how do you think about failure and
how should we we deal with failure when
we see it
well
amazon is the best place in the world to
fail
and the reason for that is we have a lot
of practice
nobody likes to fail by the way failure
even when you know it's important and
good it's embarrassing
it doesn't feel good we're all human we
had a good idea we thought it was a good
idea and nobody came to the party
that happens
and
here's the great thing though
one success one winner can pay for
dozens and dozens of failures
and that is why you should fail rule
number eight be clear and honest i've
never seen you panic i've sort of you
stay the course and you sort of stick to
your script how do you do that and how
do you advise us to to internalize that
as well as a strategy well um i think
that
if you're straightforward and clear
about the way that you're going to
operate
uh then you can
operate in whatever what in whatever way
you choose and and we don't even take a
position on whether our way is the right
way we just claim it's our way uh but
you know warren buffett has a great uh
saying
along these lines he says you can hold a
ballet and that can be successful
and you can hold a rock concert and that
can be successful just don't hold a
ballet and advertise it as a rock
concert rule number nine think long term
i know you have many interests outside
of amazon tell me about the 10 000 year
clock
well i'm i'm building a clock a big
clock it's a kind of a monumental scale
it's inside a mountain in west texas
it's the invention of a brilliant guy
named danny hillis
who had been thinking about it for a
long time and it's a symbol for
long-term thinking it's a clock that you
know you kind of think of it it you know
sort of ticks once a day and
you know dongs once a century and the
cuckoo comes out once a millennium that
sort of thing so it's a and it keeps
time it's a completely mechanical clock
it's powered by thermal night day cycles
it's a very sophisticated piece of
mechanical machinery and everything is
tested to last 10 000 years it keeps
time for that long there's a lot of
stuff to think through because it's
synchronized at solar noon and um there
could be in ten thousand years it turns
out there could be three year periods
where you have no sunlight at solar noon
uh asteroids hit the earth and change
the axis of rotation of the earth we
have to account for things like that
um the uh and so beyond just the pr the
normal procession of the earth so it's a
very complicated mechanical piece of
equipment but what's the purpose you
would say this is an odd thing to do to
spend any time on
and um
the i think symbols are really
important symbols can be very very
valuable and we have as a species become
so omnipotent on planet earth that we're
really going to have to start thinking
longer term it can you know in a lot of
different ways it's it and
um
and
you can accomplish so much if you think
long term that you can't if you think
short term so if i
said to you you know i want you to take
this mission i want you to solve world
hunger in five years
you would rightly just
turn down that mission you would say
that's not possible why would you even
bother trying but if i said to you
let's solve world hunger in 100 years
now that's really that's actually much
more tractable now you can think about
it and you can say okay well how do we
create the preconditions that are
necessary to solve world hunger and so
long-term thinking is a huge lever
and and i think it gets harder to do
as the speed
of
of invention and civilization changes in
part because
it sometimes doesn't make sense to think
long term if everything is changing so
quickly
and that's why you know kind of taking
that back to the customer needs that i
was talking about before you need to
find those things that we know as a
society that we'll want even 100 years
from now and then make sure that we go
about uh go about working on those
things and rule number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus clips
is have fun
you can hear him coming a mile away
how about the laugh it's something i've
always had no it's unique in the family
i embarrass them at movies uh you know
the dean of dot-coms jeff bezos has
billions of reasons to be laughing you
laugh as a beacon they know you're
coming that's right
i always tell people sometimes i get you
know we'll have a good
quarterly conference call or something
and and wall street will like our
quarterly results and i'll get
people will stop me and say
congratulations on your quarter and i
say thank you but what i'm really
thinking is
that quarter was baked three years ago i
right now i'm working on a quarter
that's going to reveal itself in 2021
sometime
and that's what you need to be doing you
need to be out sort of you know two or
three years in advance
and
if you are and then why do i need to
make 100 decisions today if i make like
three good decisions a day that's enough
and they should just be as high quality
as i can make them take your choices
aren't your gifts this is something that
um i would i think
is super important for young people to
understand and for parents to preach to
young people
it's really easy for a talented young
person to take pride in their gifts they
can say you know i'm really athletic or
i'm really smart or i'm really good at
math
and that's fine you should celebrate
your gifts you should be happy but you
can't be proud of them
because they're gifts after all they
were given to you
what you can be proud of is your choices
how did you decide to use your gifts
did you study hard did you work hard did
you practice the people who really excel
combine gift
gifts and hard work and the hard work
part is a choice you get to decide that
and that
is something when you're looking back on
your life you'll be very proud of when
you buy over the internet amazon do you
ever get the wrong order is anything
ever wrong what do you do do you call up
and complain or you don't have any
problems no i i i i'm a customer of
amazon hopefully like all of you in this
is there one person full-time service is
your account in this room who's not an
amazon customer see me right afterwards
and i'll um i'll walk you through it
it's um
i i yeah i get i have problems sometimes
um and i and i treat them like
the same way i treat a problem that i
would get from customer my email address
is famous and i keep it and i read it
it's jeff at amazon.com i don't see
every email that i get anymore because i
get too many but i see a lot of them and
i use my curiosity
to pick out certain emails so i'll get
one from a customer and there's a defect
you know we've done something wrong
that's the usually people are writing us
not always but usually the writing is
because we've screwed up their order
somehow
and i am
so i look at this and for some reason
something seems a little odd about that
one and so i'll ask the team to do a
case study and and find real root cause
or causes it's usually causes real root
causes and then real root fixes
so that when you fix it you're not
fixing it for that one customer you're
fixing it for every customer
and that process is um a gigantic part
of what we do so i would treat my if i
have a failed order or some bad customer
experience i would treat it just like
that amazon has 14 leadership principles
and this is the one that often catches
people a little by surprise
because one of our leadership principles
is that good leaders are right a lot
and
it sounds kind of like well
great but
is there some way that i can practice
being right a lot
and you're not gonna regret all the time
but i do think you with practice you can
be right more often and i've observed
people who are right a lot and i notice
a few things about them the first is
that people who are write a lot they
listen a lot
and people who are right a lot change
their mind a lot
and
people who write a lot
they seek to disconfirm their most
profoundly held convictions which is
very unnatural for humans so humans
mostly as we go about life
we're very selective in the evidence
that we let
seep into us and we like to
observe the evidence that confirms our
pre-existing beliefs
and people who are right a lot
work very hard to do that unnatural
thing of trying to disconfirm their
beliefs
when i started amazon it was 25 years
ago i started amazon in 1994.
when i went to seek investors the first
question i had to answer is what is the
internet
none of my investors had ever heard of
the internet
and uh
the
the the the the idea that i had in mind
was to build a bookstore i realized that
we could build a store which would have
every book
ever printed in any language in print or
out of print and we could do that online
it would be impossible in a physical
store and that was the founding idea of
amazon
and but did i expect what would happen
today no you know we started
uh i've been at amazon when it was one
person me
when it was ten people when it was a
hundred people when it was a thousand
people and today
when it's you know more than seven
hundred thousand people and approaching
seventy thousand people just here in
india
so
no i did not predict that and actually i
think if anybody had predicted that they
would have needed to be immediately
institutionalized in a mental facility
because it's not a normal thing to have
happen my dream when i started amazon
was that one day we might be able to
afford a forklift
so it's been a very
uh
fun journey for me and by the way i
still tap dance into work i'm having so
much fun one of the reasons we have been
able to extend into new business areas
and first new product categories going
way back we just sold books and then we
started selling music and dvds and
electronics and toys and so on and then
we've extended
into electronic reading with kindle
the reason customers have been receptive
in large part to our new initiatives is
because we have worked hard to earn
trust with them
earning trust with customers
is
is a valuable business asset and if you
uh
mistreat their data
they will no they will figure it out
customers are very smart you should
never underestimate customers my
grandparents would take me every summer
starting at age four
every summer
kind of to give her a break really
for the whole summer so i'd be with my
grandparents and on their ranch in
catulla texas which is halfway between
san antonio and laredo
we lived in houston
and uh so we would make the five hour
drive out to catoola they'd drop me off
spend a couple days there then they'd go
back to houston i'd spend the summer and
i went every day the ranch uh with my
grandfather to help now a four-year-old
boy
on a ranch
in south texas is not a lot of help
um but i didn't know that i thought i
was helping and and then as i by the
time i was 16 i actually was helping
so i have you know i i can
i can
suture up a prolapsed cow
i can fix windmills
my grandfather was so resourceful
and that he made his own veterinary
needles he would take a little piece of
wire and pound it flat with a
with like a oxyacetylene torch
and then drill a little hole through it
and then we would do we did all of our
own veterinary work some of the cattle
even survived
and um
uh
so we had but we had great fun out there
you know um we
built barns and welded things and he
bought a d6 uh caterpillar bulldozer
used like
1955 model year
for five thousand dollars was completely
broken the gears were stripped and then
we spent you know a whole summer
repairing that the first thing we had to
do to repair it was build a crane to
take the gears out of the transmission
and so
you know what i learned from watching
him was just how resourceful he was he
didn't ever call a repairman he figured
it out this work-life harmony thing is
what i try to teach young employees
actually and senior executives at amazon
too but especially the people coming i
get we're asked about work-life balance
all the time
and my view is that's a debilitating
phrase
because
it um
it implies there's a strict trade-off
and the reality is if i'm happy at home
i come into the office with tremendous
energy and if i'm happy at work i come
home with tremendous energy and so it
actually is a circle it's not a balance
and
and i think that that is uh
is worth everybody
paying attention to you want to have you
never want to be that guy and we all
know we all have a co-worker
who is that person who as soon as they
come into the meeting they drain all of
the energy out of the room
you can just feel the energy level go
that you don't want to be that guy so
you want to come into the office and
give everybody a kick in their step one
of the precursors one of the
foundational things
to being able to take risk is to have
had some kind of support from somebody
you have to have some mentors you have
to have somebody who loves you these are
the kind of things that build up and
allow you
to kind of you know jump off into
uncharted terrain and do something new
because you know you have
a support system of one kind or another
and uh and i certainly did so
for me i just want to point out that
i've i i feel very strongly that
um
there's a lot i've won a lot of
lotteries uh amazon is one of the
lotteries that i've won but i had a big
lottery with my parents my dad is a
cuban immigrant he came here when he was
16 years old didn't speak any english
my
his is a great guy
and my
mother
had her
had me when she was 17 years old so she
was a pregnant 16 year old in
albuquerque new mexico in high school
which was not cool
and uh
she made it work and her her parents my
grandparents helped her with that whole
thing and made made that all work and if
you don't get that kind of support
somehow it doesn't have to be your
parents sometimes people get lucky it's
a grandparent or it's a friend or a
family friend or a teacher it can be
somebody but you need that somebody has
to step into your life and that's a
lottery that i suspect a lot of people
in this room have also won just like me
you know you don't choose your passions
your passions choose you and i would
always advise young people actually
anyone
you know to get in touch with what
you're really passionate about and it's
a gift to have a passion some people are
lucky they have more than one passion
they have two or three
and that gives you energy
you can't force the passion on yourself
it just doesn't work you can try but
it's unlikely to succeed your stock at
one point i think went to a hundred
dollars but then it went down to six or
something like that at the peak of the
internet bubble our stock peaked
somewhere around 113 dollars
and then after the internet bubble
you know busted open our stock went down
to six it went from 113 to six in less
than a year so my annual shareholder
that year starts with a one word
sentence and that one word sentence is
the word ouch
so
most of those internet companies of the
dot com era are out of business
yeah you survived what was that that
made you to survive and virtually the
rest of them are gone um i it's very
that whole period is very interesting
because the stock is not the company and
the company is not the stock and so as i
watched the stock fall
from 113 to 6 i was also watching all of
our internal business metrics number of
customers profit per unit
you know
everything you can imagine defects etc
every single thing about the business
was getting better and fast and so as
the stock price was going the wrong way
everything inside the company was going
the right way and um
uh i you know so i wasn't we didn't need
to go back to capital markets we didn't
need more money the only reason you know
a financial uh bus like the internet
bubble bursting is it makes it really
hard to raise money but you know we
already had the money we needed so we
just needed to continue to progress i
talk a lot about um willingness to be
misunderstood that's a really important
thing to have if you're going to do
anything new or different in the world
it is going to be misunderstood
sometimes by
well-meaning critics sometimes by
self-interested critics you'll get all
kinds
and
it's okay
it's all part of the process the only
way to avoid criticism altogether
is to be completely conventional in
everything you do
and
so how do you respond to the criticism
what do you do what's the right thing to
do
well i think
the first thing you do
is you ask
are the critics right you listen you ask
are they right or even if they're not
completely right
is there some piece of it that's right
that you can be inspired by and then if
you decide by the way that the answer is
no that you believe you have conviction
that what you're doing is the right
course
then no force in the world should be
able to move you
you should have a deep keel but
if you decide that your critics that
there is something
then you should change
um and
i give you an example from the early
days of amazon of one where we refused
to change this we were small enough that
most people didn't pay much attention to
us or care about us taking you way back
to like 1995 1996
we pioneered this thing called customer
reviews
and i got a letter one day from a
publisher
a book publisher
that said hey
you must not understand your business
you're losing sales because you're
allowing negative customer reviews
on
the book detail pages why don't you just
put positive reviews
and i thought about this and i thought
no
he's wrong we don't make money when we
solve things we make money when we help
people make purchase decisions
it was a different framing
and so
getting to today's news
you know we listened to our critics and
we decided
the framing that we have been using all
these years is
competitive compensation we look at what
other job opportunities there are and
what the competitive compensation levels
are and we offer competitive
compensation and actually
non-competitive world leading benefits
packages but just competitive
compensation
and
so
in light of this you know thinking about
this and trying to decide do we want to
change
we realize we just made a decision well
you can offer competitive competition or
you can decide to lead
and as soon as we framed it that way
we're like let's decide to lead it's
great i think people will follow what
was it the critics said that caught your
eye
basically they were saying
they were if you read between the lines
because a lot of the specific criticism
was not correct but if you read between
the lines what they really wanted us to
do they said because you could also say
look there are so many companies all the
fast food companies there's you know the
baristas and there's you know wait wait
a second why
are you focusing on us
but that what they're really saying is
we're focusing on you because you're a
leader
and we want you to lead
that's what they're actually saying and
as soon as you recognize it that way
instead of it feeling like criticism it
feels empowering they're asking us to
lead because we're a symbol of
an innovative
iconic company we're a gold standard for
innovation
we should lead never
chase the hot thing whatever it is
that's that's like trying to catch the
wave and you'll never catch it you need
to position yourself and wait for the
wave and the way you do that
is you pick something you're passionate
about so
that's the number one piece of advice
that i give to somebody who wants to
start a company
or or start a new endeavor inside of a
bigger company
make sure it's something you're
interested in something you're
passionate about
missionaries build better products
and so
i would take a missionary over a
mercenary any day mercenaries want to
you know
flip the company and get rich
missionaries want to build a great
product or service and you know one of
those great paradoxes it's usually the
missionaries who end up making more
money anyway there's one reason
we have done better than most of our
peers
in the internet space you know over the
last six years it is because we have
focused like a laser on customer
experience and that really does matter
i think in any business it certainly
matters online
where word of mouth is so very very
powerful you know if you make a customer
unhappy they won't tell five friends
they'll tell 5 000 friends so we are at
a point now
where we have all the things we need
to build an important and lasting
company and if we don't it will be shame
on us you mentioned that you wanted
innovation to inspire this next
generation why is it important to you
why is it so important you personally to
make that happen
well i think you know i was very lucky
kid i was inspired by
invention and self-reliance from a
number of different people and from you
know even
watching the apollo program as a little
boy and i think when little kids get
inspired you'd never know what might
happen uh it's a big deal and everything
about our society
gets better over time i really do
believe that i'm an optimist you know
the myth of the good old days is usually
just that a myth
we have better medicine than we've ever
had before
everything you know all of that is
invention it's people figuring out
antibiotics it's figure people figuring
out new kinds of
biomedicines biotechnology
it's things that have been figured out
with the kind of communication that we
have the freedom of speech we have now
with the internet
there are so many things that are
getting better and a lot of that is
powered
by
uh invention how do we get young people
re-engaged with government service
well
i think one thing and i i look at this
at amazon too so i i don't think it's
just government service i think a lot of
these government organizations are large
organizations
and large organizations
have a set of problems and i worry about
this at amazon i want us to have
this the scope and capabilities of a
large organization but the spirit and
heart of a small startup company
and and and i and i think that so large
organizations one of the things
that happens is that the rate of the
decision-making velocity goes down
and it gets hard for large organizations
to make decisions quickly it's trivial
for
a 50-person startup
they make decisions like this
but a 500 000 person company like amazon
or a giant government agency there's a
lot of levels of review and different
things and it can really slow and by the
way that young people don't want to work
at a company with a slow decision-making
process it's just not as fun as working
at a startup company or somewhere else
where so i think you can do that and
even in a large organization i think if
you if the leadership this is all about
leadership if the leadership focuses
on increasing the decision-making
velocity of the organization
you will get everybody will be happier
it's more fun
everybody will be happier at work
and you'll get younger people because
that's what they want you can also do
every single person who works in a large
company you get to decide are you going
to help increase the decision-making
velocity
are you going to bring energy to the
room we all know we all have those
people we work with them
as soon as they walk in the room
the whole
room the energy level goes up somehow
they bring energy to that
conference room and we also all work
with people who are the opposite like
the second they walk in the room the
whole room
deflates
and you don't want to be that second guy
um
you want to be that first guy and you
and we all get to choose that we all get
to decide that
so anyway i think you can do it in big
organizations and i think one of the
things that makes big organizations less
attractive to young people is just
sometimes we're slow and you can fight
that and you can fix it if you look over
over long periods of time you know look
over hundreds of years
and look at the
average sort of life cycle of a new
technology what you find
is that it's getting compressed and
compressed and compressed so the rate of
change is getting faster and faster
every decade that goes by there are sort
of more important discoveries per unit
time than there were in the previous
decade
and
and a lot of these discoveries
tend to
uh
you know have
two uses i mean technologies in gen you
know tend to be agnostic with respect to
whether they could be used for good or
used for evil
and i think that you know over the next
years we are going to
face a lot of very tough decisions
as a society in
in how we make sure
that we are harnessing those
technologies
for good purposes
i think
liberty giving people the freedom to
uh you know as long as they're not
hurting somebody else do what they want
is super important i think it's the core
essence of the american dream and i
think at times we as people get confused
about it i mean i think one of the
things that you
see
come up
in various places
and people talk about it under different
labels sometimes they talk about it as a
lack of personal responsibility and
other kinds of labels but what it really
is is is i think people
should you know carefully re-read the
first part of the declaration of
independence because
i think sometimes we as a society start
to get confused and think that we have a
right to happiness but if you read the
declaration of independence it talks
about life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness nobody has a right to
happiness you should have a right to
pursue it and i think the core of that
is liberty i think it's the very rare
idea that can be done by a single
individual almost everything that is
going to
change the world solve a problem improve
something these are usually big efforts
and they require you know teams a team
working together to really get something
important done and that has been the
story of amazon.com every step along the
way we've had a team here
that is
is making this work i mean
i don't know even even at the smallest
scale you have to figure out how to get
help from your friends from your family
members uh from uh people that you can
hire in those early days i think without
that it would never work you need people
who
and this is very tricky you need people
who are
experts
in a certain domain area because the
world is so complex today it's really
hard to invent something if you're if
you're not an expert if you don't have
the underlying
tools at your disposal and know what's
going on you can't you know invent
something in neurosurgery without
knowing something about neurosurgery um
it's just going to be very difficult
because we're very advanced and that's
true in every every field of endeavor
but to really be an inventor you have to
combine that expertise
with the beginner's mind you have to
have a certain
child-like ability
to
not be trapped by your expertise and
that fresh look that beginner's mind
once you're an expert is unbelievably
hard to maintain but great inventors are
always looking they have a certain
divine discontent and they may have seen
something a thousand times and still it
occurs to them that that thing even
though they're accustomed to it could be
improved and that's you know you have to
look for people like that and i also
think cultures support that you know you
can't even if you're that kind of person
if you're in a culture that doesn't
support failure you know willingness to
fail is critical for invention
willingness to be misunderstood for long
periods of time you know most inventions
don't really work that well in the
beginning they're clumsy they're little
toddlers they're always falling and
tripping
um and so you have to have a a a culture
in your organization that supports this
kind of
stumbling and wandering uh you know you
want just because you're wandering
doesn't mean you're lost
and that's a really important thing to
keep in mind when you're trying to
invent i very frequently get the
question
what's going to change in the next 10
years
and that is an interesting question it's
a very common one i almost never get the
question what's not going to change in
the next 10 years and i submit to you
that that second question
is actually the more important of the
two
because you can build a business
strategy
around the things that are stable in
time and so as you pointed out in our
retail business we know that customers
want low prices
and i know that's going to be true 10
years from now
they want fast delivery
they want vast selection it's impossible
to imagine a future 10 years from now
where a customer comes up to me and says
jeff i love amazon i just wish the
prices were a little higher
you know how you i love amazon i just
wish you delivered a little more slowly
impossible and so the effort that we put
into those things
spinning those things up
we know the energy we put into it today
will still be paying dividends for our
customers 10 years from now and so those
when you have something that you know is
true
even over the long term you can afford
to put a lot of energy into it on aws
the big ideas
are also pretty straightforward it's
impossible for me to imagine
that 10 years from now somebody is going
to say i love aws
i just wish it were a little less
reliable
or i love aws i just wish you would
raise prices
it should be a little more expensive
or i love aws and i wish you would
innovate and improve the apis at a
slightly slower rate
none of those things
you can imagine and so the big ideas
in business are often very obvious
but it's very hard to maintain a firm
grasp of the obvious at all times
but if you can do that
and
continue to spin up those flywheels and
put energy into those things as as we're
doing with aws
over time
you build a better and better service
for your customers on the things that
genuinely matter to them from the very
beginning
in 1994 when i came across this fact
that the web was growing at 2 300 a year
i was working on wall street very
specialized kind of investment bank
called a quantitative hedge fund a
company called d.e shaw
and
i
when i decided i was going to go do this
crazy thing
i went and told my boss
and he said well hmm let's go for a walk
so we went on a two-hour walk in central
park
and uh he actually thought it was a good
idea he's a very smart guy his name is
david shaw he's one of the few people i
know who has a fully developed left
brain affordable right brain just a
super smart guy
and he said this is a great
idea but it would be a better idea for
somebody who didn't already have a good
job
and
that was actually a compelling argument
to me and so i went away he convinced me
to think about it for two more days and
it was very hard to make that decision
and
until i found the right framework in
which to make the decision i think
because i know there are a lot of people
who are interested in entrepreneurial
activities out there i think this could
be useful
it's it's that it's the right framework
for me anyway to make the kind of
decision was a regret minimization
framework so i projected myself into the
future and i'm 80 years old and i'm
looking back on my life what do i want
to have done at that point i want to
minimize all the regrets that i have and
i knew that when i was 80 there was no
chance that i would regret having walked
away from my 1994 wall street bonus or
any of that kind of thing i wouldn't
even remember that but i did think there
was a chance that i might regret not
having participated somehow in this
thing that i thought was going to be
very exciting called the internet
and
and i also knew that if i tried and
failed i wouldn't regret that so once i
thought about it that way it become
became incredibly easy to make that
decision there are a couple of other
things
that are essential for innovation and
invention that are not as fun
one of them is you have to have a
willingness to fail
you have to have a willingness to be
misunderstood for long periods of time
if you do something in a new way
and i don't care
what it is
people are initially
going to misunderstand it relative to
the traditional way and they will
they'll be well-meaning critics
who
you know genuinely
want the best outcome but they're
worried about this new way
and they'll also be of course
self-interested critics
who have a vested interest
in the
traditional
they have some profit stream tied to the
traditional way
but
but doing things and if you want to if
you never want to be criticized for
goodness sake don't do anything new
so
it's it's it's okay though if you have a
willingness to be misunderstood for long
periods of time
if you have a willingness to fail
then what you can do is you can ramp up
your rate of experimentation so
successful invention successful
invention is inventions that customers
care about
it's actually relatively easy to invent
new things that customers don't care
about
but successful invention
if you want to do a lot of that
you basically have to increase your rate
of experimentation
and that you can think of as a process
how do you go about
organizing your
systems
your
people
all of your assets your own daily
life and how you spend time how do you
organize those things to increase your
rate of experimentation because not all
of your experiments are going to work
just find something that you're
passionate about i would definitely on
the career advice side the most
important thing about your first
job out of school is to pick a place
where you think you're going where
you're learning per unit time is going
to be very high you can optimize for a
bunch of variables and it can get very
confusing you know where is location you
know what's the salary going to be and
all those things are worth considering
they're all important but make sure you
pull back after you've done your
analysis and say am i also picking the
place that i believe my learning per
unit time is going to be the fastest and
you learn much more from a best
practices company than you do you learn
no matter where you go so if you go work
for somebody you're like god these
people are all crazy this is insane
you'll learn a lot of negative lessons
that you can use later and you cannot do
those things but that process of
elimination method takes a long time
um so it's better to try and find a
place that has really high hiring
standards some of the basics especially
you know a place that's trying to
recruit only the you know the
you know a's higher a's and b's higher
c's and c's higher d's so you've got to
hire only a's and you need to pick a
company that's doing those kinds of
fundamental practices well because then
you'll learn so much it'll set you up to
do other things so i would say that's
probably the best career advice i give i
would definitely advise
a small stirrup company to be as narrow
and as focused as is possible to be if
you look at the original amazon business
plan
there was no hint of anything other than
books in it and it was not on my radar i
was thinking i wanted to build an online
bookstore that was it
and
you know worked way better than i
thought it would and we launched music
and that worked better than i thought it
would and we launched videos i think
it's so long ago i can really remember i
think it was actually vhs tapes is that
possible
and um and that worked better than we
thought it would and then i sent email
to customers so i picked about a
thousand customers and i said
besides the things we sell today books
music and video what would you like to
see us sell and the list came back
incredibly long tails almost like
whatever was on their mind at the moment
it was like i wish you sold windshield
wipers for my car and i was like really
windshield wipers that wasn't done the
business plan but that's an interesting
idea and so
um today we basically if you're buying
your windshield wipers anywhere else
you're probably getting ripped off um
and um
so um so it's been you know kind of one
foot in front of the other invention is
not disruptive only customer adoption is
disruptive at amazon we've invented a
lot of things that customers did not
care about at all
and believe me they were not disruptive
to anyone
so it's only when customers like the new
way
that anything becomes disruptive
and so really it's just saying that you
want to you know if somebody comes to
you with a business plan that they claim
is disruptive you should ask them to
explain it to you in simpler language
and the simpler language is why are
customers going to adopt this
um why are they going to like it why is
it better
than the traditional way it's about
definitely about leaning into the future
um and so
when you look at the kinds of things
that you want to be able to do with your
voice
uh you know it it changes for for those
of you who have used an echo the fact
that it's always on
that you never have to charge it it's
always sitting there ready in your
kitchen or your bedroom or wherever you
put it the fact that you can talk to it
in a natural way
removes a lot of barriers a lot of
friction a lot of like little tiny
pieces of friction to be able to do
things to ask what the weather is it's
easier than taking your phone out of
your pocket and what what has what
people have found over and over again is
that by removing the tiniest amounts of
friction from ordinary activities
really
people appreciate that and and it
improves customers lives one of the key
things about lean
you know defect reduction being
efficient not letting defects travel
downstream in any process if you're
going to eliminate waste or as the
japanese call it muda
you have to
have information
and um
the data center
has historically been
an information free zone as far as
application developers are concerned
you would write code
and you have no idea how it's consuming
resources you're too insulated
because you're in a pool of resources
and you can't meter it
one of the biggest still
unappreciated
benefits of aws
is that application developers
get a real sense
of which inner loop is driving all the
cost
yeah
and that's a big deal
so that and that's just starting to
that's one of the ways that
that this approach to uh infrastructure
dramatically reduces costs in our in our
data center i mean in our fulfillment
centers and in our customer service
centers
we have
um
we're always seeking to keep defects
from moving downstream so this is a
you know
a principle that was probably best
applied in the early or best first best
applied
by toyota
and they had this idea of what they call
the andon cord which basically any
factory worker could pull the cord and
stop the whole automobile manufacturing
line
and
for old school
auto manufacturing companies
that was considered crazy
absolutely insane in fact the opposite
principle was typically at work which is
you did everything possible to keep that
line running
and here toyota flipped that on its head
and they said look
anytime there's a defect no matter how
small they want you to pull the cord and
stop the whole line
and um
stopping things you know if you if you
do that in a line that has a lot of
defects initially you get a lot of end
on chord pulls and it's very expensive
and but over time if you use that
approach you eliminate the defects
closer and closer to the source
and
and the people who are
fans of
lean manufacturing and these kinds of
techniques
take almost as an article of faith
although there's a lot of evidence to
support this in very diverse industries
that the further a defect travels
downstream
the more expensive it becomes to fix
and so you want to you want to stop
those things you don't want them to
repeat and happen over and over
sometimes
you know we we expand into new areas in
two ways um
one is
kind of you know
from
from a customer need we will work from a
customer need to the skills that we need
and the other one is skills forward from
a skill set we have to a new set of
customers so
kindle is an example of a customer need
and
you know so we don't have any hardware
skills
we've been doing this for 10 years now
but we'll go back and we'll go if you go
back in 10 years we had no hardware team
we had to hire somebody to lead our
hardware group and then build a hardware
team and build some institutional
competence at it and so on
that um that's a customer need backwards
approach and skills forward a great
example of that is amazon web services
we had the skills to do aws we had
probably more distributed computing
expertise than anybody else in the world
because of the transactions transaction
systems are so complicated and hard to
build and we had a service oriented
architecture of great complexity
probably before anybody else
and so we saw we could kind of because
we were doing that we could kind of see
the
future a little bit and
decided to build aws which has turned
into you know a huge
business in its own right
and
that is uh you know you if you were
always
business is very situational and so gen
rules of thumb are good but they have to
be applied to the right situation so
sometimes the old
maxim that you should stick to the
knitting is correct but sometimes the
adage that you should stick to the
knitting is wrong
and
you know a senior leader's job is to
figure out in which situation are you
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there